in jungles close to the border with
China Rebels attack a government
position despite facing Superior armor
and Firepower these Fighters have made
dramatic gains across Shan State
strategic Hilltop bases vital to the
control of this region have also Fallen
to their forces they captured weapons
ammunition and government troops and
formed a new
Coalition our policy to work with all
resistance organizations to eliminate
the
Juna now we are fighting in the South
under the command of the Ken here in the
north we are fighting under the
Brotherhood
Alliance in the immediate future we will
also expand our operations in central
Myanmar myanmar's military is fighting
back volle is fired from artillery
batteries in bases that haven't yet been
overrun and it remains unchallenged in
the air making it hard for the rebels to
hold
ground in the Border City of chinu Hall
thousands have fled into China fearing
the military's
response we call on relevant parties to
cease fire as soon as possible resolve
disputes peacefully through dialogue and
consultation avoid escalation of the
situation and take concrete and
effective measures to ensure the
security at the China Myanmar border the
speed and success of this Rebel
offensive puts one of myanmar's key
transport arteries under Rebel control
the road to Mandalay National Highway
number three the trade route with China
that could be disastrous for the ruling
Generals in neor but Beijing has been
hedging its
beds Chinese foreign policies on Myanmar
is very complicated while maintaining a
relationship with napor and the military
government China has also been
developing relationships with armed
ethnic groups it's a challenge for the
Chinese to Les it connections with
various
parties the other concern for my's
military rulers will be the threat of
different ethnic armies coordinating
themselves to deadly Effect one of the
larger groups the Tang National
Liberation Army has been threatening to
do this for some time this success may
have shown them all that Unity is the
way forward Tony Chang Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
zero